[Music]
in Hitler house news one of the showers
are like submitted by hand-pulled news
what what's that mean
hand pulled like I can't see it like
wrong developed in the liquidity or like
hand-pulled noodles yeah
that was a more wholesome wow that's
actually wow you're better than we are
um just makes no Chinese method Hitler's
birth home will be turned into a police
station after a years long debate on
what to do with it what did they make it
into Museum yeah I don't want to
celebrate him on because isn't it weird
to have a police station there you know
what police brutality and all that stuff
going on in a different country though
his birth home so Austria Austria oh
it's a birth home that's different from
his Nazi residence he was a baby that's
different that's like Trump home yeah he
was actually born here like you just
convinced yourself I mean when he was a
babe it was it like what was it tainted
I don't think so I think the different
creeps like it was show Hitler as a baby
though Hitler a baby he has the same
haircut hilarious why does he have the
same haircut can we say that he was a
cute baby or not it's pretty cute show
me we can say that right okay so he was
born in the second floor back in 1889
which when I read this I was like oh
[ __ ] he's exactly a hundred hundred
years younger than us oh yeah you're
also born in yeah a hundred year old
[ __ ] has this this plaque here this -
Megan - the [ __ ] movie I can hold you
most vagan a Mercedes Benz
so it actually says for peace breathe
freedom and democracy
never again fascism millions dead are a
warning cool so actually the government
the Austrian government has been renting
the property from this one person who
had who her family has owned the
building for many generations and so
back in 2012 she had refused federal
request to make renovations which then
sparked Austrian
efforts to take ownership of the
building can I do that can I just take a
building for me if you own it well so
the country's government ended up
seizing the building that sounds pretty
fascist to me back in like no more
fascism and they're like you know what
I'm just gonna take your that's ours now
the government says this is mine every
government in the world even here they
have laws like that or they can just
seize like if they want to build a post
office for example they can just seize
your house and be like there's people
who are like oh well off you million
they refuse to sell and then and then
like now you just have like skyscrapers
in this little tiny house and I'm like
like enough but effects the gullies if
it's the government it's it's much
harder in America
yeah it's harder but they can still do
with the building back in 2017 which
then led her to file a complaint that
eventually landed before Austria's
highest court and so the Supreme Court
of Justice in Vienna ruled that she
should receive one oh eight hundred and
twelve thousand euros which is about
eight hundred eighty eight hundred and
ninety eight thousand dollars in
compensation
Wow the euro went down didn't it just
sure did they went down used to be like
one point five of the dollar you should
put on like an air B&B like stay in
Hitler's bedroom that's a good money
those are getting almost a million
dollars front that's tight well they're
really trying to be out for old hours
building like that that she had nothing
to do it just because she inherited it
huh that's dope yeah but they were just
gonna steal it from her well but the big
plaque that says we should never be
fascist ever again and then the
government comes in and takes your
private property that's [ __ ]
hilarious that's the irony behind that
yeah hey we need this property but we
have this [ __ ] stone here
representing that fascism shouldn't be
your life other clues it when was it
ever a museum or anything so did Hitler
have a rattle that had no rattle sounds
anyway and so it's like that's why you
came in little hints yeah like swastikas
but like baby's hand drawing right yeah
little designs like that
with a complicated tear so during World
War two it was an art gallery and a
library and it was also used as a bank a
school and a center for people with
special needs
but now they're saying that it will be
turning to police station to deter any
neo-nazi people whom wanting to make
into a shrine and stuff and so oh that
makes sense because if it's a museum all
of the visitors might be neo-nazi
worldwide so they decide it's making it
to police station and they will start
doing that next year you will leave next
year's 2020 uh whole last decade is done
holy crap why needs a it's in like five
or six weeks mm-hmm I'm not ready it's
crazy it's right on the corner we still
don't have flying cars [ __ ] we're
rolling into the new when you think
about what a museum is it's really just
like a hoarders collection of historical
shake it's haunted I would say Museum
recently I went to the broad like last
week and all this [ __ ] was like [ __ ] is
this like is it not worth it
yeah but it was literally like a piece
of cardboard painted red stuck on
another piece of cardboard it was
selling for like I don't like those ones
I like the historical stuff like anyone
who finds that [ __ ] like the weird stuff
awesome like you don't know [ __ ] you
don't know yourself museums
yeah those are 12 museums right yeah
yeah I did see this one thing at a
contemporary Museum though it's like
they just rigged a bunch of scissors
with sensors so wherever you walk the
scissors start [ __ ] going that's fine
so then it follows you and then yeah a
tensile yeah but you could just run
around the whole place in the scissors
like toss my hair up and get my split
ends dude you [ __ ] dope yeah it's
like a fine yeah it's fun for you cuz it
was really high it was watched
there's that recent movie that came out
with the takos ytt
about the jojo rabbits oh my god recent
episode of Brigham Morty I heard but I
haven't seen it yet
Tiger Hitler hiked up
yeah just making sure but it seems like
I met take up is he the best he's okay
okay so you didn't see that he doesn't
know I exist
yeah that was this close eyes shoulders
I met Michael Fuji do it selfie where he
wasn't even looking at the cabinet I met
Michael man but I didn't get a picture
with him but I shook his hand and said
I'm huge fan
did he write he directed Heat I still
like Tyco yzz better sorry you're wrong
you've never seen heat then fine I'm
drunk so yeah so [ __ ] days okay watch
Joe Joe rabbit watch it's a fan of wrong
you would like Michael Mann ah but if
you yell let you have it
what's you about what's heat about
action move the guy move [ __ ] he
Pacino and De Niro
if you want to know what heats about Oh
Pacino they seem like Oh goddammit heat
is about an unstoppable force base in
movable object things started clicking
in her head he's like cooking you know
denial
they were hiding opposite of each other
sick like you met him I use drugs then I
met Michael Mann strippers man I went to
a screening of the movie thief that he
did and with James Caan and it was
[ __ ] dope movie because what's great
about him as a director is that he
actually does the things that he's
filming so like when he had James Caan
robbing a alt a pain fault he actually
had him holding a [ __ ] like hot
whatever rod and he's shoving it into
the side of the vault and actually
cracked the wall right like that's
Michael Mann man he's he is so technical
and you know I like the opening scene of
Dark Knight that everyone loves a
houseful Melinda is highly inspired by
heat Michael Mann by the initial robber
even the soundtrack and everything that
everything well Tiger ytz had three
microphones because one of them didn't
work and then so he got another one
another guy brought another one so at
one point he had three funny already
keep holding the microphones that don't
work Michael Mann forever true I don't
know I [ __ ] love him he was awesome
I would sound doing a Q&A of Georgia
rabbit so back to Hitler and stuff
okay expanding on what a museum is like
if you're not into the right thing like
if you're into historical artifacts and
stuff you gather a [ __ ] ton you put it
inside of the building you call it a
museum if you're like my mom and you're
into like [ __ ] old trampolines and
rusty metal furniture and [ __ ] you fill
a house with that you try to call it a
museum everyone's like you're [ __ ]
hoarder this is weird
what's the difference between an old
trampoline and a new one you have to
keep them up the same you have to keep
both because you saw your three year old
kid jumping on that one and you really
liked it but the model and Technology
hasn't really changed right no [ __ ] no I
would never buy a [ __ ] trampoline
already accidents and deaths happen it's
like the smaller set no [ __ ] razors
and you're like you're a space for like
eras so it was so fun where you do the
aerobic like leaping yeah yeah yeah I
just need an extra air to do something
you can just run and jump on it and then
get a little extra air for for some
reason I like trampolines magazine
people jumping all weird I get the half
little trampolines and so what I went on
my first big trampoline and I was like
this is way too much trampoline I don't
need this much trampoline nobody does
record it if you ever do get I want to
record it put it on YouTube two million
views you feel invincible cuz you're
like oh if I crash it's not gonna hurt
and you try to jump more and more and
then pretty soon like you're really up
in the air and then you're like I'll
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] don't get down on this
and it gets kind of scary
well you might like you like Sky TV or
go to you've never been to uh what's
that's guys on yeah thank you [ __ ] oh
that one I've been there a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]